this guy pointed to his wife when I said
[Applause]
can I watch
this is white on white love right now
oh that's awesome thank you for coming
available
thank you
I'm gonna get out right now
what's your name
[Applause]
well I I look like one of your students
[Music]
oh nice
oh how does it feel to watch your sister
make out with uh
okay let's do it
[Applause]
okay thank you guys so much for coming
oh she got a fake tattoo with my name on
it
um
wow okay
I don't know
[Applause]
let's go back to business
is really about like the intellect so
yeah
uh well thank you for coming you know
like a mythological conclusion is we
have to do anal sex with a closer
[Applause]
and I'm doing those poppers now
there's some blue
uh well thank you for pointing around
sir
[Applause]
thank you
thank you for uh pouring out your
complexes
that was awesome I am really having a
good time
[Applause]
oh God
so I'm single
[Applause]
anymore I should have closed on that
oh
[Applause]
anyone else
yeah
and then I'm going to get some mono
going
I sort of new strain
coronavirus to shame
okay Wendy
how are you
[Applause]
doing no problem now
I have to bring you on the road with me
this is so good
in 10 minutes at least of just Wendy
tongue action
you were just practicing mouth to mouth
resuscitation
your job as a school nurse
yeah unless you had a fake tattoo and
everything uh what well let's let's keep
it moving let's let's go past that let's
suppose
it is about kissing me all the time I
get sick of that
today
yeah I'm sexually active
I've been uh I've been having lots of
sex uh recently you know I actually uh
got a girl into my hotel room tonight
which last night which might happen
tonight
foreign foreign